hey can i talk to you
what's up
think you could drop me off at the movie
saturday night i'm seeing janet can't
mom do it
mom's going out
and
i kind of want to go with marcus oh so
you're trying to go on a secret date
kinda i don't know how i feel about this
come on it's just a movie have you been
out with him before never alone how old
is this boy 13 do his parents know about
him what are you mom now you're my
sister you boys is weird will you take
me or not
fine
thank you thank you thank you
you best not be hugging him like this or
that date's gonna be over real quick
i'll pick janet up first then we'll go
get marcus
okay
so what move are we saying
what do you mean we you think i'm
letting you go to the movies alone with
him what do you think is going to happen
nothing's going to happen because i'm
going to be there
relax i'm not going to sit with you i'll
be in the back but you'll be watching me
it depends what move are we saying
beauty and the beast
i'll be watching
[Music]
so
how serious is it with you two well
we've held hands hugged once and we
haven't kissed but we did share a straw
wow pretty serious i haven't even been
on a date yet
we got pretty serious before you ever
took me on a date
pull up with that
can i ask a relationship question
of course who said i love you first
funny you should ask
so no one's gonna say anything for the
rest of the night
wouldn't be the first time no one said
anything when the subject of love came
up i said something that doesn't count
missy if you said i love you to marcus
and he said samesies would you be okay
with that
and before you answer remember who
agreed to take you on a secret date
don't ask her she's a kid she held hands
and shed her strong
should we just forget and go home fine
by me does the back seat get a vote you
put me on the spot i never said that to
anyone before me neither and it didn't
go well
seems is
i'm sorry
i'm not even sure what it's supposed to
feel like
well if you felt it you'd know
i know that i like you
a lot
more than anybody else
really
yeah
by the way well marcus is in the car you
can't be the slam
like a virus heartbreak can also spread
[Music]
once it does it's hard to contain
[Music]
in some cases you can try to reboot and
start over
but it makes you appreciate those early
days when your hard drive was clean
[Music]
and the world was full of possibility
rewrite my beliefs and stories